up in here my girl natasha castles and
we have got a special guest in the
building this guy is on world star or
media takeout this dude is like the most
talked about dude on tv right now
pissing all the ladies off we got stevie
j in the building yeah yeah he is what's
up stevie what's going on with you man
hey man i just i gotta ask you dog do
you have sex with every girl you come in
contact with uh
not everyone else not everybody ever
been about 70 baby
that all depends on how i'm feeling when
i wake up that morning you know damn
this guy stevie j i watched i usually
try to refrain from um
a lot of vh1 television but i i watched
the first episode online of of uh love
and hip-hop atlanta and then i just had
to watch all of them dog i was it was
like i was like on crap man like
so entertaining bro i can't believe it
was a pleasure it is a guilty pleasure
it is man i i just can't believe you
though sometimes on this show dog that's
why that's what makes me me you know
saying i do what others don't you know
what i'm saying i'm surprised you ain't
got lorraine and bobby did yet bro well
you know
i can't get lorraine to buy it i kick
him out after so
you're like you're that guy everybody
loves to hate though
yes all right yeah it started with me
i'm the number one hater i can't i match
you every time
i can't believe no i can't believe half
of the stuff you do on the show before
it's on sunday if i can have sex with
him
i was watching the show and i saw
jocelyn and i know she was getting a lot
of hate i wasn't aware of all the hate
she was getting online because i i
didn't watch the show right away right i
probably watched it maybe two weeks ago
and i thought she i think she's bad
she's beautiful dog
all my choice now this is a question
that i can ask because this is being
videotaped but not live is jocelyn and i
know you guys are putting together a
little love making videos is this
correct i mean you know we may
um she like anal
she likes a little bit of this
and a little bit of that and a little
bit of that she like she like girls more
than me
that is awesome
what's the over under on threesomes
you've had with johnson i'm gonna start
at five over under five i mean you know
you're just gonna have to stay tuned and
you know the book is coming i can't
reveal too much right now but we get it
popped you know if you really wanted to
get it popping y'all just drop a sex
tape
at home look at my phone i'm surprised
that hasn't happened yet
you know
yeah now um a video just came out of
your baby mama punching you in the in
the whatever the hell in the chest yeah
she was mad you know trust me i got a
crazy baby mama yeah
i'll show you how to deal with them i
got some
we gotta we gotta get together on this
man we could write a book we should man
um
i'll write a book on a woman's fury
yeah you should be scared of that
no no no no no just you or not because
you know not at all
there's no one on time hey but at this
point with mimi i mean is it just like
any girl that you are that's in your
life do they just accept the fact that
you're banging everybody i mean not that
i'm banging everybody but you know i'm a
different type of dude um you're like a
mormon yeah i get my money look at me i
i get my money you know i said i take
care of my children you know what i'm
saying and the ladies in my life i'm
just a different type of individual
you're like a 2012 pimp like it like
actually in the sense of the word i want
to say 2012 more like 50 12.
she you want some futuristic pimping
yeah
this guy
oh this dude is so awesome to take away
from the 90 million records i sold in
the three grammys you know what i mean
the eve sex tape yeah yeah i pioneered
the sex tape thing you know you did it
man shout out to eve man shout out to
those guts bro um she had you know she
got some nice
thing was all right y'all were like you
guys are serious for a while right yeah
yeah you guys were real i groomed that
thing
man you broke her end
yeah
this guy i opened up the books you
opened the books you wrote the original
book with eve yes man have you seen eve
lately um on a couple pictures and
whatnot no pictures i mean like in
person no i haven't seen that what's
what's up man
so stevie um you have all these
beautiful women in your life i have to
tell you something though jocelyn i
understand why you decided to get into
this music relationship with her yeah
because she's super hot right but her
music is freaking terrible though do you
think so i think i don't know which one
you heard whatever's on the show um
i don't know it sounded just like a
terrible like ragged tone like she got
it she i don't know talking about the
bylaws song is actually sounding pretty
good i'm sure it is because she's
popping but
i mean do you ever just like um
when you when you met joslyn you met her
at the strip club yeah i met at the
street club that's awesome yeah but yeah
her song is selling pretty well i
appreciate you taking girls off the
strip club you know yeah you know you
got some strip clubs here yeah we do we
do i mean
tonight maybe you might have to pull a
couple of chicks out and
start seasoning this
loving hip-hop phoenix
i may start that
you might have to start that yeah um
what other adventures you got going on
we i we read something online that you
might be doing some sort of video or
like a love making guide or something
like that yeah we might make the love
making god we've got the book coming you
know what i'm saying we got the t-shirts
coming you know we got we got the music
coming we got taran grant eddie rap life
stevie j project
um bbod young gavin you know what i'm
saying we're just working what does this
book consist of
it's you know just the way players play
a manual for the ladies and the man and
emmanuel for the gentleman you know i'm
saying in my perspective on how to
handle things that's what's up man and
um the love making video uh
natasha's here she's actually in a
relationship right now that she just got
into issues oh how fresh is it it's very
fresh how long you've been talking to
this guy three months and they haven't
had sex yet so uh we're just going to
throw that thank you thank you
but that's what she said no no no no
trust me she would tell me she's about
that life okay you about that life
what advice can you give my friend
natasha who's in a fresh relationship
with no relations at the moment hang
with me a little bit you know i'm saying
just then you could just have sex with
him no no no i keep it faithful see
unlike you know what your beliefs are in
a relationship listen my thing is like
this at one point every woman you know
saying has been a jump off
this is probably true what are you
calling a jumper i'm gonna say you'll
jump off at one point have you ever been
a jump-off
how do you know
have you never been a jumper you've
always been somebody's girl yeah you
never took it one night not at all never
where's the light
detector coming out it's in the bag
every man cheats and every woman then
they jump off bottom line yeah that's
what i want to ask you man because i was
asking your booking beautiful girl yeah
she is amazing gorgeous what's up thank
you bonita bonita yeah
bonita she is awesome uh she said that
you're a really dope i was like is he
really like you know is he like he was
on the show you know is he a douchebag
um
i want to say a douchebag i just say
like douchebag
you do a lot of douchebag stuff which
might be a you know stuff that's
classified as douchebag dirtbag dirtbag
douchebag
first episode you answered your phone in
front of
your baby mom and she was in the car
jocelyn was calling i don't know i i
threw something on the tv at that point
who does that you did that i was so mad
how could you do that though you should
have gotten socked right there well you
know i've been stuck i got stocked on
tmz by the other day you know everybody
take it you're okay with that yeah
that's okay
but you know what the girls still stick
around so you must be doing something
right
we're gonna be at the revolver lounge
tonight in scottsdale yes we are
a couple of new shows that i'm executive
producing you know i'm saying we need
some beautiful women you know saying i
want to be groomed you know saying i
want to be led in the right direction
this guy sounds like mr white folks
right now y'all know who mr white folks
is who's that he's a famous pamper oh
yeah okay okay mr white folks yeah yeah
he's the wife of chicago
shout out to stevie j this guy is
inspiring man listen we gotta get it
right now you know what i mean tonight
it's going night is going down revolver
lounge and scottsdale are you actively
still uh piping out uh
you know the jocelyn and the mimi well
you know my beefcake green game is crazy
i know you probably got a bunch of new
uh chicks that are not you know i'm i'm
looking for new ladies to to just
cultivate you know what i'm saying not i
don't know
sex i like to cultivate their minds you
know because ladies need some guidance
sometimes you gotta brainwash your
chicks right they're not even about to
brainwash you know it's about both of
you i would say this
she needs a little bit of information
i'll tell you this the images we'll just
instead of saying brainwash we'll say
this
that sounds a lot better right i'm god
right now he's so happy yeah
can we have a shot tonight yeah no
question we can have you we can pop some
more
invite some of your things yeah cause
i'm sure you guys know you got a whole
bunch of that might not watch this oh
uh thank you for confirming josslyn
mike's anal and uh lesser words i mean
you know hey foreign
can we um you got to put out a second
table johnson because i would love to
watch that okay for you specifically i
mean whatever
she's so thick man she's like baby
mother is gonna go upside your head
tonight when she sees this
hitman stevie j how much hate do you get
on the tweets well you know
a lot but it's okay i got rhinoceros
skin so they could talk you know i'm
saying just keep talking okay why you
can't while you get these checks right
yeah that's all it's about
i got deed out my man out in the
building what's your twitter doc d
angelette id that angel lady we here we
gonna be at scottsdale tonight at the
revolver lounge come through about
eleven come on all beautiful ladies all
my players out there let's have some fun
you know what i'm saying just turn up
turn up there it is thank you for coming
through man thank you for having me i
aspire to be like
thanks
yeah yeah there it is i appreciate it
though are you like d-dot d-dot yeah
you mad son what the [__]